broadcast from the most powerful places
in the west the message they thought was
clear i'm authorizing additional strong
sanctions the package of massive and
targeted sanctions the largest and most
severe package of economic sanctions
it won't have felt clear enough to the
country facing conflict
the reality weighed on those talking
today sanctions so far have failed there
will be direct measures now on putin and
his foreign minister the message the
west wanted to land on this we're strong
and united
we are
impacting upon 70 percent of the banking
system
in russia we are preventing the regime
from financing the war effort and this
is meaningful this is important and we
are all behind it
but that may be fraying just look at
this from a former polish and eu leader
your sanctions are pretended he said
those who blocked going further a
disgrace and there are major things
they've not done no block on russia's
energy market germany actually completed
a large order today and no move to block
russia from a system called swift an
interbanking messaging platform that
enables global payments
for a financier once deported from
russia it would work and be worth it if
you were to to unplug russia from swift
it would basically knock the country
back to the dark ages the italians are
worried about selling their luxury goods
into russia
the belgians are worried about selling
diamonds into russia
but the way i look at this is that all
these people with these narrow financial
interests
cannot hijack
the national security of europe
but economies are at stake
blocking russia from swift would have
serious financial implications not just
in the city of london it would also
block payments for things like food and
medicine that are often counted as
humanitarian exemptions and it could
also push other adversaries towards
alternative platforms in many ways it
encapsulates the central tension of
these decisions that balance between
pain and principle
and there will be plenty pain already
not least for those in this business
aeroflot flights here banned british
carriers blocked in return
in essence companies can't do any trade
involving a russian bank more products
can't be sold there all of this has a
cost and we'll all have to pay it the
shadow of war hangs over here too helen
smith sky news